let's answer some questions about the
Israel Gaza
[Applause]
War it's been almost 2 weeks since Hamas
attacked Israel and Israel responded
with a massive assault on Gaza thousands
have been killed the UN says Gaza is
facing a humanitarian
catastrophe there's anger across the
region about the impact on Palestinian
civilians and talk of this spilling into
a much bigger conflict there running
Street battles at the moment protesters
have been trying to break through the
security barrier outside the they're
throwing stones the whole region is at
the brink of folding into the
abyss I've been asked a lot of questions
on Instagram and I've picked three to
answer on issues that have come up a lot
let's start with what will happen to all
the civilians in Gaza well the short
answer is we don't really know what we
do know is that the situation ation
right now is dire and it will get worse
unless the war stops and humanitarian
Aid is allowed in remember Gaza is a
tiny densely populated strip of
Palestinian land it's run by Hamas but
more than 2 million people live there
and can't get
out Israel's bombing campaign has been
the fiercest in recent memory Israel
says it's targeting Hamas Fighters but
air strikes have also hit residential
buildings schools and
Clinics
on Tuesday a strike on a hospital in the
north of Gaza killed hundreds of people
Gaza Health officials say it was an
Israeli air strike the Israelis blamed a
misfired rocket from the armed
Palestinian group Islamic jiad last week
Israel cut off food fuel water and
electricity supplies into to Gaza and
supplies of everything are running
[Music]
out Israel did allow drinking water into
Gaza for about three hours on October
16th but it was a fraction of what's
needed according to the UN the UN also
says people are drinking salty water
from agricultural Wells and they're
concerned about the spread of disease
then there's the mass displacement of
people more than half of gaza's
population have had to leave their homes
there's also been a huge movement of
people from the north of Gaza to the
South while Israeli air strikes have
continued everywhere Israel told
civilians living in the north more than
a million people they had 24 hours to
evacuate ahead of a possible ground
Invasion something the UN said was
impossible without devastating
humanitarian consequences and we still
don't know for sure how many people did
leave and how many stayed not everyone
could
leave others chose to stay or have now
returned because conditions in the South
are so bad bombardments did not stop in
the southern parts of the Gaza Strip
that's in h Raa and
and that's why so many families who have
evacuated South are going back now
because at least at least um if we're
going to die we're going to die with
digity in our homes Egypt is the only
country other than Israel that shares a
border with Gaza so there's a big focus
on opening up that crossing the Rafa
Crossing as an aid route which brings us
to our second question why can can't
Egypt send supplies or open the Rafa
border now there are a lot of issues
tied up in that question the backdrop is
that Egypt and Israel generally have a
pretty Cooperative relationship they
signed a peace deal in 1979 and Egypt
has often been a mediator in previous
conflicts between Israel and Hamas even
in so-called normal times Israel
maintains a Siege on Gaza controlling
who and what goes in and out and that
includes coordinating with Egypt about
the movement of people and goods through
the Rafa Crossing they're complicit with
Israel in The Siege U of Gaza which has
been going on and this is very hard for
Palestinians and other Arabs to accept
but it's a it's a reality understanding
the current situation at the Rafa
Crossing depends on whether we're
talking about Aid getting in or people
getting out on the aid issue Egypt
always said it's been ready to send in
supplies but that they couldn't without
a safety guarantee from Israel and
there's been a lot of Israeli bombing
near the Rafa Crossing after US
President Joe Biden's trip to Israel
Israel now says it will not prevent
humanitarian assistance from Egypt as
long as it is only food water and
medicine for the civilian population in
the South and as long as no supplies
reach Hamas there are trucks lined up at
the border ready to go Egypt's now
agreed that 20 can go in but it's not
confirmed when now when it comes to
people getting out the politics is even
Messier most of the diplomacy is focused
on Palestinian duel Nationals so
Palestinians who are also citizens of
other countries the US for example
estimates there are around 600
Palestinian Americans trapped in Gaza
right now usually dual Nationals would
be able to get in and out of Gaza pretty
easily using the rafic crossing but not
now I a US citizen my country told me to
come here we went through hell coming
through here we don't know what's going
on why we were told to come and when are
we going to get out of here it's
hopeless my message is to secretary
blinkin if we were Israelis would this
happen to us then there's everyone else
in Gaza given how dangerous Gaza is
right now A lot of people are wondering
why all Palestinians can't flee to
safety across the border to Egypt well
that's a scenario that Egypt and other
Arab states have ruled out Egypt sees
that scenario as a national security
risk that would spread gaza's crisis
into Egypt itself and it says National
Security is a red line it won't cross It
also says it won't take in Palestinian
refugees as a matter of principle it
says it stands by the goal of a
two-state solution meaning a Palestinian
State alongside the state of Israel and
that taking in large numbers of refugees
would undermine
that Jordan's taking a similar position
many Palestinians are worried about this
too that is a red line uh because I
think that is the plan by certain of The
Usual Suspects to try and create de
facto issues on the ground no refugees
in Jordan no refugees in Egypt if Egypt
were to open its border and a million
Palestinians would leave Gaza and go to
Sinai in theory just for temporary
protection the fear is they never go
back they don't want to suffer another
neba where half the Palestinian
population in
1947-48 was driven out of Palestine or
fled because there was war and this is
something that people are very aware of
now on the on the Egyptian front now our
last question which is actually two
questions where is this going to go how
is it going to end while no one can
predict the outcome of this here are
some things to consider there's the risk
that it becomes an even bigger War
remember Hamas is part of an alliance
that includes the armed group Hezbollah
in Lebanon and Iran Israel has already
been exchanging fire with Hezbollah
across its shared border with Lebanon
and Iran's foreign minister has warned
that it could take measures against
Israel if they don't deescalate while
Israel says it's ready for for a bigger
fight we are prepared to fight uh if
needs be on two fronts uh we have the
ability to do so we can do it on more
fronts as well another thing to think
about is how Israel's ground Invasion
might play out we've been expecting it
for almost a week now Israel's called up
hundreds of thousands of army reservists
and troops and tanks have been amassing
in southern Israel near the Gaza border
but the longer a ground Invasion doesn't
happen the more people are questioning
whether the Israeli plans could change
there's there been a slight shift in the
messaging from the Israelis on Tuesday
an army spokesperson said everybody's
talking about the ground offensive it
might be something different and now
there's also so much anger in Arab
countries about the hospital strike in
Gaza some analysts think that could also
play into Israel's calculation on a
ground Invasion remember there's a lot
of diplomacy going on behind the scenes
between Israel the US and Arab leaders a
ground Invasion would mean urban Warfare
and even more casualties humanitarian or
organizations are warning that it would
be disastrous for Palestinian civilians
there's also a huge risk that the
captives being held by Hamas and Gaza
around 200 according to Israel would end
up getting hurt or killed the Israelis
are walking into a trap and they know it
the Israelis are very good in their Air
Force they can destroy we've seen what
they have done in Gaza they can level
the city but they cannot guarantee a
success of the Infantry so how is this
going to end well that depends what you
think about Israel's stated goal it says
it's about wiping out Hamas but many
people are questioning what that really
means or if it's even possible they
could kill many or all of the Hamas
leaders but that wouldn't do anything
other than spark an even
more um determined and and more militant
movement that would follow some years
down the road Hamas is uh an idea um
it's a visceral political National human
response to Decades of occupation and
subjugation the truth is that the more
they attempt to control Gaza and isolate
Gaza and contain Gaza the less secure
Israel becomes not the more secure the
story of Gaza the struggle of the
Palestinians does not begin and end with
Hamas when you say Victory what do you
mean what's going to be of Gaza what can
we do to leverage this Unthinkable round
of
blooded into a
positive path forward there should be
choreography to address the core issues
of this
conflict security is one of them but
occupation if you don't deal with
occupation you're doing nothing and I'm
saying that is in
Israeli
[Music]